Bekommen wir langsam Klarheit an der Tabellenspitze? Schalke gewinnt in Elbersberg Düsseldorf, entlässt nach dem 1 zu 2 gegen Holstein Kiel Markus Anfang und holt Alexander Ende die Wortwitze. Sie haben uns das ganze Wochenende versüßt. Wir sprechen darüber mit Anna Lautenbach und Lisa Höfer und jetzt geht's los.
Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Lagerflieg vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Und Augsburg ist oben.
Rossi zu Kurzabwehr, lang genug für Willi Landgraf.
Wagner, Martin Wagner.
Und das 1 zu 0. Markus Kort aus dem Gewühl. Alexander Schur!
Der Blick auf andere Ligen. Ja, willkommen zurück zur Ligatur, zur 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Mein Name ist Eva-Lotta Bohle und ich freue mich sehr, dass ihr wieder eingeschaltet habt zu dieser Ausgabe der Ligatur. Ich hoffe, ihr habt in den letzten Wochen noch nicht zu viel von mir gehört, in diversen Ausgaben dieses Formats. Denn– Spoiler– ihr werdet es im April nochmal tun, also freut euch drauf, I don't know. Aber wie immer sitze ich hier nicht alleine, das heißt, es wird kein, weiß ich nicht, 90-minütiger Monolog und das ist auch gut so, denn ich freue mich wirklich riesig, dass wir hier heute in unserer schlechten Laune bezüglich unserer Vereine mehr oder weniger vereint sind. So haben wir uns diese Folge auf jeden Fall schon selber angekündigt, also ganz top. Und damit herzlich willkommen zurück nach ihrer Olympiapause durch ihre Arbeit für die Sportschau. Hallo Lisa Höfer.
Lisa, ergänzt gerne.
Ja, ich glaube, das macht total Sinn, was du sagst, Anna. Und ich würde das sogar noch ein Stück weit verstehen können, würde man in der Tabelle ein bisschen weiter oben stehen. Ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen der Punkt an der Stelle, ist auch wieder so eine Binsenweisheit. Aber wenn du halt Tabellenletzter bist und du bist im Moment zwei Punkte hinten dran, dann verstehe ich auf der einen Seite, dass man sagt, okay, lass irgendwie gucken, dass du dir nicht wieder 2, 3, 4, 5, es gab ja auch schon die eine oder andere richtig hohe Klatsche, fängst gerade nicht gegen den Abstiegskonkurrenten. Aber Null, Null, das hilft halt nicht. Also das hilft, führt noch mehr, auch wenn es denen auch nicht richtig hilft, als Münster, weil Münster halt wirklich ganz, ganz hinten drin steht. Und auch mit Blick auf das Restprogramm, ich glaube, das werden wir wahrscheinlich bei jedem noch so ein bisschen im Blick haben, finde ich ja ehrlicherweise, hat Münster so das größte Brett mit den nächsten fünf Spieltagen. Also ich habe hier Schalke, Hannover, Darmstadt, Elbersberg, Bielefeld. Ja, also da hätte vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Mut, zumindest auch Kiel. Das war ja das Spiel die Woche vorher, das habe ich ehrlicherweise nicht gesehen. Ich saß aber in der Sport-Tour-Redaktion neben dem Kollegen, der den Spielbericht schreiben musste und der auch ganz viel Spaß hatte, sich dieses 0-0 anzugucken, wo ich halt auch sage, also ich verstehe auf der einen Seite den Gedanken, aber es hilft dir so wenig, dass man da eigentlich ein bisschen mehr vielleicht investieren muss, um auch auf das Tor zu gehen. Ja, seit Oktober kein Heimsieg ist ja eine Statistik, die ich auch noch mir ausgeschrieben hatte in der Vorbereitung. Das wird halt schwer. Also bei aller Liebe, ja, zweimal die Null hinten, die steht, aber puh, ich glaube nicht, dass das noch ein gutes Ende nimmt, wenn ich mich zu so einer ganz, ganz leichten Prognose hinreißen lassen müsste.
Ja, also zur Untermahnung vielleicht in ein paar Zahlen. Also erst mal Platz 18 ist es, 28 Punkte, 31 zu 47 Tore, ich habe es eben schon mal gesagt, 6 Siege, 10 Unentschieden. Also diese Menge an Unentschieden, die ist schon relativ hoch und eben 13 Niederlagen. Vorm Tabelle sagt eben auch Platz 18, 3 Niederlagen, 2 Unentschieden. Man ist jetzt halt eben seit, zum dritten Spiel in Folge auf Platz 18. Die tiefste Platzierung in der Hinrunde war Platz 12 und seitdem ist man wirklich nur noch im unteren Drittel zu Hause. Und mein Problem ist, glaube ich, also gucken wir auf das Kiel-Spiel und auf dieses Fürth-Spiel. Man hatte kumuliert drei Schüsse aufs Tor. Und diese drei Schüsse aufs Tor kommen alle vom Spiel gegen Fürth. Also man hat mehr Torschüsse generell, aber wirklich die, also auch, glaube ich, nur eine Großchance im Endeffekt. Das reicht halt in dieser Phase nicht. So, und das ist auch hier meine Hauptproblematik, wo ich so ein bisschen sehe. Und das war, glaube ich, auch das, was von vielen, ich glaube auch von Münster-Fans zum Teil kritisiert wurde. Also es gibt auch einen längeren Kommentar dazu im Forum, dass eben so, ja, wo man nicht so wirklich weiß, also setzt man jetzt alles auf diese Heimspiele noch, wo wir eben wissen, da haben sie jetzt eben zuletzt nicht so wahnsinnig viele Punkte geholt. Lisa, du hast es gesagt. Also wenn wir generell mal auf die Tabelle schauen, da ist man heim, steht man eben auf Platz 15, auswärts auch auf Platz 15. Also ob das jetzt, du kannst doch nicht mal gerade eben sagen, ok, dann holst du da jetzt eben die Punkte, das ist eben schon ein Problem. Und ich weiß es nicht. Also, naja, auch, ich glaube, in dem Spiel führte fast 70 Prozent Ballbesitz. Gut, ich meine, wir reden gleich noch kurz über sie. Da eben auch dieser komplette Philosophiewechsel zu einer Mannschaft, die eben sehr, sehr viel Ballbesitz hatte, zu Beginn oder unter Alex Ende zu wenig. Ich weiß halt nicht, ob das wirklich einfach zu groß war. Weil natürlich ist es gut, dass du, ja, du hast es super rausgearbeitet, aber es bringt dir halt nichts, wenn du dir vorne halt nichts mehr erarbeitest. So, weil Mauern bis zum 34. Spieltag wird dir halt absolut gar nichts bringen und einfach nur hoffen, dass da vorne einer reingeht, weil ich sehe trotzdem keinen, also, correct me if I'm wrong, aber ich sehe eben keinen offensiven Ansatz und das ist genau das, was Alois Schwarz am Ende auch immer seinen Job gekostet hat. So, ja, also, ich kenne keinen, der jetzt gesagt hat, wo Alois Schwarz in den letzten Jahren war oder Offensivfußball unter Alois Schwarz. Ja, wir haben aber Spaß gemacht. So, also, wie gesagt, ich finde das auch valide zu sagen, wir müssen die Gegend Torflut einstellen und alles, aber zu dieser Phase in der Saison, ich sage es gerne nochmal, super tolle Fußball-Weisheit, du brauchst halt Tore, dringend.
Ja, absolut. Also es ist kein guter Zeitpunkt, um den Sprint einzustellen. Das, ja, ist wild, irgendwie. Ich bin wirklich, wirklich gespannt, weil ich finde es einfach eine komplett krasse 180-Grad-Wendung zu einem komischen Zeitpunkt. Mal gucken, was dabei rauskommt. Ganz egoistisch gibt es mir einfach ein bisschen Hoffnung für meinen eigenen Verein.
Komisch. Fair point. Ja, also ich weiß nicht. Ich meine, natürlich, klar, wenn du am Ende 0-0 gegen Schalke holst, sagt niemand, okay, schlecht. Aber auch da, also ähnliches, was ich eben schon mal gesagt habe, auch das bringt dir nichts in dieser Phase.
Hol das 0-0 erstmal und dann, wie du sagst, also ich weiß nicht, ob ich da jetzt bei diesem Programm unbedingt ein 0-0 sehe. Das ist ja jetzt, also es geht ja für alle auch noch um ein bisschen was. Kommen wir ja auch gleich zu, Schalke, Hannover. Also pfuh, weiß ich jetzt nicht. Und das sind ja auch Mannschaften, die gerne Tore schießen und die auch Tore schießen können, also ja, schwierig. Also glaube ich schon schlechte Konstellation an der Stelle für Münster.
Ja und dann muss man eben sagen, man hat eben auch gegen zwei Vereine gespielt, die jetzt auch nicht von Offensiv-A, weiß ich nicht, Kraft nur so strotzen. Also wie viel Aussagekraft hat dann die Null, die hinten steht? Das ist für mich dann halt die Frage. Also ich würde mir– klar, es kommt als Bielefeld-Fan immer so ein bisschen komisch– aber ich würde mir aus Preußensicht große Sorgen wirklich um dieses Endprogramm machen. Und auch das, was eben in diesem Vorungsbeitrag durchschwang, klang jetzt nicht sonderlich. Also ich habe echt so das Gefühl, die Euphorie, die ist auch irgendwie weg. Du merkst das, wie ich finde, was so durchkommt im Stadion zum Teil. Also ich meine, vielleicht ist es ein Vorteil, dass es eben noch eine Derby gibt in diesem Endspurt. Ja, weil wir wissen alle, das kann vieles freisetzen so. Aber ob das reicht, da würde ich erst mal daran zweifeln. Vorsichtig ausgedrückt. Aber ich würde fast sagen, dann leiten wir mal über zu einem anderen Part dieses wundervollen Spiels. Das ist ein Spiel, was übrigens unserem lieben Kollegen Michael Fischer dazu– er hat nur beschrieben, es ging vorher darum, dass es endlich Netto-Spielzeiten eingeführt werden sollten. Und dann hat er nur dazu geschrieben, zum Glück gab es die in diesem Spiel nicht, sonst wäre das sein letztes Fußballspiel gewesen. Also Kraft an Michael Fischer an der Stelle nochmal, dass er sich das 90 Minuten angucken musste. Für die Spielvereinigung führt das eben Platz 17, 30 Punkte, 40 zu 61 Tore, 8 Siege, 6 Unentschieden und 15 Niederlagen. Vorm Tabelle Platz 13, 2 Siege, 1 Unentschieden, 2 Niederlagen. Nach dieser guten Phase, Mitte Februar bis Mitte März, gab es jetzt 3 Spiele ohne Sieg. Und man muss sagen, in der denkbar schlechtesten Phase in der Saison. Im Spiel gegen Münster kann man sich vor allem, ehrlich gesagt, noch bei Silos Prüfrock bedanken. Sonst war das sehr dünn. Man sieht vor allem den Ausfall von Dennis Rebeni, auch Marco Ion, der gerade erst wieder zwei Spiele zur Verfügung stand, hat sich im Spiel gegen Münster verletzt. Anbruch des Wadenbeinköpfchen bei Noel Futtgold, rot eine Sperre wegen fünfter gelber Karte. Also auch da sieht es jetzt in der Offensive gar nicht mal so rosig aus. Ich sage, so ein bisschen die Spielvereinigung führt. Sie ist für mich im Abstiegskampf so ein bisschen dieses Gänseblümchen. Also mal schafft es, mal schafft es nicht. Zwischendurch war diese Pflanze einmal komplett tot. Ja, und dann kam sie wieder raus, so ein bisschen den Frühling anvisiert. Aber, Lisa, ich weiß immer, ich putte dich an den Spot, so als Clubfan. Aber was machen wir denn mit der Spielvereinigung?
Ja, was machen wir denn? Also ich sage mal so, es kommt ja noch ein Derby. Das haben wir ja gerade auch schon beim Blick auf Münster erwähnt. Da bin ich auch sehr, sehr gespannt drauf. Also ganz verstehe ich ehrlicherweise führt diese Saison nicht. Du hast den positiven Zwischensprint ja gerade schon so ein bisschen angerissen. Also wenn ich jetzt gerade hier Fürth gegen Münster mir angucke, dann frage ich mich schon so, wie haben die 2-1 gegen Hannover gewonnen? Wie haben die einen Punkt gegen Schalke gemacht? Das ist schon, also es für mich irgendwie zeigt, wie absurd diese Liga ein Stück weit ist. Ja, also so richtig viel Hoffnung. Also ja, ich will es gar nicht sagen, so richtig viel Hoffnung, sich befürchtet ehrlicherweise an vielen Stellen auch nicht. Mit Blick auf Stressprogramme dann deutlich mehr als bei Münster. Das sage ich schon, aber die Statistiken, du hast ja gerade schon ein bisschen was aufgezählt. Wenigste Torschüsse, wenigste Flanken aus dem Spiel, wenigste intensive Läufe. Ich gucke mir das immer gerne noch mal so ein bisschen an, bevor ich hier reinkomme, weil es ja ein ganz gutes Gefühl auch gibt, so wo steht eine Mannschaft und wenn selbst der Trainer, das fand ich irgendwie sehr bezeichnend, was Heikenvogel so nach dem Spiel gesagt hat, naja, ich habe gemerkt, wir können hier nicht gewinnen, naja, dann muss ich halt schauen, dass ich nicht verliere. Ja, das tut mir fast schon weh, auch wenn ich weiß, man will ja kein Mitleid von Clubseite haben, aber ich hoffe sehr, dass Föhrt es noch schafft, weil persönlich fände ich es total schade, wenn es kein Döring mehr gäbe. Ich glaube, das versteht auch jeder Fan an der Stelle, weil es doch immer ein Highlight ist und irgendwie dazugehört und das schon, also es würde einfach sehr, sehr fehlen an der Stelle, gerade wenn man in der 2. Liga spielt und es nicht damit begründet ist, dass der Club aufsteigt, was ja jetzt auch nicht so in Abseemacher Zukunft passiert. Ja, ich bin so ein bisschen ratlos an der einen oder anderen Stelle, muss ich gestehen, wenn ich so bei Föhrt bin. Also ich habe hier Restprogramm gerade noch mal drauf geschielt. Darmstand, ja, wird auch nicht so einfach werden. Aber Bochum, Nürnberg, Hertha Düsseldorf. Ja, also es ist nicht aussichtlos. Es ist nicht Hertha und Lauten, das war doch eine Sache.
Hertha und Lauten, die haben noch richtig Aktien trotzdem im Auf-
und Abschiedskampf. Ja, und für beide gibt es nicht mehr so richtig viel. Also ich bin jetzt nicht hoffnungslos, wenn ich auf Föhrt blicke. Aber es wird schon schwer, um es vielleicht so zu formulieren. Ich meine, vielleicht reißen sie das Ruder rum und es kommt der nächste Zwischensprint. Vielleicht ist es auch ein– ich will es gar nicht sagen– vielleicht ist es auch ein Derbysieg, der dann irgendwie noch mal einen positiven Push gibt. Das würde ich mir natürlich nicht wünschen. Aber ja, also ich finde, das ist für mich eine ganz komische Saison an der einen oder anderen Stelle. Verstehe ich auch immer noch nur bedingt.
Annalisa hat gerade schon so ein paar Zitate genannt. Ich werfe dir noch mal zwei Sätze vor. Also Vogel hat eben auch auf der Pressekonferenz gesagt, ich bin nicht zufrieden mit dem Spiel. Ich bin aber zufrieden mit dem Punkt, den wir dann mitnehmen. Und sagt dann auch, wir haben es heute nicht verdient, mit drei Punkten nach Hause zu fahren, weil wir uns suboptimal verhalten haben. Was macht man mit solchen Aussagen?
Ja, unser Trainer, kleine Fußnote, hat in der Pressekonferenz nach dem Spiel gegen Bochum gesagt, wir waren zu Tor ungefährlich. Fühlst du das? Das fand ich irgendwie auch. Also, ja, kann man vielleicht da ganz passend zu assoziieren. Irgendwie kann ich das logisch nachvollziehen, dieses, ich bin unzufrieden mit dem Spiel, deswegen bin ich zufrieden mit dem Punkt. Das ja irgendwie erst mal passt das ganz gut zusammen. Ich erinnere mich halt im Kontext Fürth in dieser Saison wirklich an schreckliche Zusammenbrüche defensiver Natur. Also unglaubliche, ja, unsortierteheiten, gerade so im defensiven Verbund, bei denen ich ehrlich gesagt verwundert bin, dass der Trainer das überhaupt noch sortieren konnte. Also ich finde, die Situation, in der Fürth steht, ist tatsächlich insgesamt, würde ich sagen, eher Erfolg als Misserfolg, weil ich das zwischen, also ich finde nicht, dass man das halt kommen sehen, dass Fürth dann noch mal so mitmischen würde, tatsächlich im Abstiegskampf, weil ich vor dieser, ihr habt das gerade Gute Phase genannt, vor dieser guten Phase gedacht habe, die sind einfach weg. Gerade, weil diese gute Phase ja auf Spiele fiel, in denen man nicht denkt, dass ein Abstiegskandidat da groß was holen würde. Also das ist zum einen dieses 2-1 auswärts in Hannover, aber dann schlagen sie auch Elbersberg 2 zu 0. Und das hatte ich tatsächlich, also wirklich exakt überhaupt nicht auf dem Zettel. Und meine These da ist, dass die 2. Liga vor allem dann einen neuen Dreh bekommt, wenn Mannschaften wie viert in einer, wie damals Situation auf Mannschaften treffen, die denken, das wird schon. Weil, also es ist ein Effekt von dem, von dem die Braunschweiger Eintracht massiv profitiert. Wir haben auch im Winter dann 2-0 gegen Schalke gewonnen. Weil ich schon glaube, dass das vielleicht auch Effekte sind, gegen die sich dann ein sogenannter Favorit auch gar nicht immer wehren kann, weil du ja die Zahlen siehst und irgendwie denkst, naja gut, dies und das, das große Ziel vor Augen. Und wird es da irgendwie nur so eine kleine Zwischenstation, das kriegen wir schon hin. Und ich glaube, dass dafür aber auch abgeschlagene Mannschaften in der 2. Liga zu gut sind, um sich die Chance dann entgehen zu lassen. Das wäre eben meine Arbeitshypothese zu dieser guten Phase. Die aber offenbar nicht gleichbedeutend mit einer konstanten Leistungssteigerung des gesamten Teams einhergeht. Weil es ja auch manchmal so ist, du hast diese Erfolgserlebnisse, also gewinnst du spielerische Sicherheit, also werden deine Spiele sukzessive besser. Dieser Effekt scheint in 4. nicht eingetreten zu sein. Und eine Prognose ist sehr schwierig, finde ich. Also ich sehe nicht, dass die noch mal daran anknüpfen, was sie zwischenzeitlich gezeigt haben. Nehme aber den Trainer als so stoisch war. Ich übe mich hier heute in positiven Wörtern für Dinge, die man vielleicht auch anders formulieren könnte. Und ich glaube, die Nervenstärke von Heiko Vogel und sein Hang und vielleicht Nervosität nicht eins zu eins nach außen zu transportieren, könnte ein Vorteil werden der Spielvereinigung.
Ja, also was ich glaube, ich befürchte auch immer noch sagen muss, du hast eben angesprochen, man hat das Gefühl, das überträgt sich nicht so richtig auf die Spieler. Also ich glaube schon wirklich, dass diese Auswahl von Srebreni vielleicht wirklich saisonentscheidend gewesen sein kann, wie böse das auch klingt. Ja, ich muss halt sagen, also alle Spieler, die sonst bei Führer vielleicht individuell immer wieder gezeigt haben, was sie reinbringen können. Klaus war komplett unsichtbar, Furtkoi hat nicht wirklich was gezeigt. Also wirklich, Sielas Prüfrock ist so noch der heimliche Held, der natürlich auch wirklich immer so ein bisschen die ärmste Sau war, muss man ja fast sagen. Der aber, wie ich finde, einer der Spieler ist, die sich schon so im Laufe, also gefühlt ist er für mich der Einzige, der sich schon weiterentwickelt hat, auch mit dieser positiven Phase. Ich meine, klar, es ist bitter, du wechselst in der 63. Minute Jone aus, äh, ein, und in der 78. musst du ihn eben verletzungsbedingt wieder auswechseln. Dafür kommt dann übrigens Julian Green, finde ich auch ganz interessant. Also ich glaube, wir brauchen nicht darüber diskutieren, dass einfach dieser Kader weiterhin ein Problem bleibt, obwohl ich weiterhin der Meinung bin, dass du da eigentlich mehr rausholen hättest können. Aber ja, also ich meine, ich muss sowieso sagen, wenn ich auf dieses Spiel gucke, ich verstehe noch, okay, Münster wechselt insgesamt nur dreimal in dieser Partie, obwohl sie noch einen Meier Höfer und einen Batista Meier offer, also bis vor allem einen Batista Meier offer Bank haben, okay, vielleicht wolltest du da nichts riskieren, checke. Aber wenn du in deinem Spiel siehst, dass du eigentlich die bessere Mannschaft bist und von Fürth kommt nichts gleichzeitig führt, da konntest du eben noch nicht mit der ersten Halbzeit zufrieden sein. Dass er dann erst so spät wechselt und so spät eingreift in die Partie, fand ich dann auch schon bemerkenswert, ehrlich gesagt, aus Trainer-Sicht. Weil ich hatte dann auch irgendwann das Gefühl, er ist mir eine Spur im Spiel schon zu zufrieden mit dem 0-0. Und das, also er wechselt dann ja eigentlich auch, bis auf Arifi für Klaus, gefühlt nur defensiv. Also er nimmt Dietz raus, er nimmt Reich raus. Ja gut, dann muss er eben nochmal verlässungsbedingt, dass er ein guter Teil ist, die andere Seite. Also aber, ja, habe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so ganz verstanden, sowieso dann natürlich aber auch die Empfehlung. Mehr die tiefere Analyse zu diesem wunderbaren Spiel, hört ihr natürlich gerne eben für der Flachbass nach. Da werden, glaube ich, vielleicht werden da Fragen beantwortet, die wir hier jetzt gestellt haben. Ich kann sie auf jeden Fall nicht beantworten. Ich dachte also dafür, dass ich bei Führtschammer einmal dachte, sie wären irgendwie auf einem richtig guten Weg, verstehe ich nicht. Wie gesagt, sie sind für mich das Gänseblümchen der Liga. So ein bisschen positiv gesehen. Don't know, ob man das so sagen kann, aber gut. Bevor wir den Abstiegskampf verlassen, habe ich noch ein paar Ankündigungen zu machen. Anna und Lisa dürfen kurz eine Minute durchschnauben und durchatmen. Zunächst einmal danke natürlich für das Feedback zur letzten Folge und generell für euren Input natürlich immer auch zu dieser Folge, aber generell immer zwischendurch aus. Das leitet mich aber zu einem kleinen Punkt über zu der Forumsdiskussion, die es eben vor allem im Nachgang zu dem Hertha-Dresden-Spiel gab. Ich habe das eben schon mal angekündigt, per se. Ich freue mich darüber, dass ihr diskutiert und dass ihr diesen Input-Thread so gut nutzt. Allerdings sage ich das hier jetzt einfach nochmal. Es ist halt gerade, weil wir eben nicht wie bei der Bundesliga der Männer oder so wirklich Spieltagsendungen haben, sondern einen gesammelten Thread. Weiß ich, dass das schwierig ist, manchmal dann halt wirklich beim Sportlichen zu bleiben, aber per se ist es einfach für mich, vielleicht als Moderatorin, aber vielleicht auch für andere Forum-Userinnen, ein bisschen schwierig, wenn dann eine lange Diskussion über Pyrotechnik und Choreos und so beginnt. Und ihr könnt gerne über alles diskutieren, was ihr wollt, bitte, aber auch immer, da schließe ich mich Max an, in einem Rahmen, die wirklich Diskussionskultur fördernd ist und nicht ich bin übrigens der Meinung und niemand kann die ändern. Das bringt uns in einer Diskussion nichts und ehrlich gesagt habe ich mich ein bisschen bestätigt darin gefühlt, wie dieser Threat, ich habe da quergelesen zum Hertha-Dresden-Spiel, dann weitergeführt wurde. Das hatte halt irgendwann noch nicht mal mehr was mit diesem Spiel zu tun, obwohl so der Threat ist. Es gibt einen Threat zu Pyrotechnik, es gab einen Threat dazu und da wurden hinter Sachen diskutiert, wo ich ganz ehrlich sagen muss, weiß ich nicht so ganz, ob das wirklich auch Ziel bringt für so eine Community ist, wenn man da so drüber diskutiert. Dann gab es einen Punkt dazu, dass im Rasenfunk wohl immer negativ über die Polizei gesprochen wird und jetzt das gar nicht lohnend erwähnt wird oder ähnliches. Dazu sei gesagt, ja ich weiß, das gebe ich auch gerne zu, ich bin, da ich in erster Linie Fußballfan bin und sehr viel fahre und sehr viele Fußballspiele besuche und dadurch sehr viel Kontakt zu der Polizei tatsächlich auch habe, sicherlich kann ich da nicht ganz unbeteiligt auf die Sache blicken. Ich bin weiterhin aber auch der Meinung, man darf der Polizei durchaus die anders bewerten, als man Fußballfans bewertet, weil wir sprechen hier von einem Staatsorgan und von Fußballfans. Dass beide Seiten Treize bauen, können wir uns glaube ich schon einig sein, aber so viel noch dazu. Und genau, sowieso bitte seid freundlich zueinander, bitte geht einander nicht an. Ich mache Fehler, andere machen Fehler. Genau, und wenn ihr sowieso schon wisst oder meint zu wissen, wie meine Meinung zu etwas aussieht, warum wollt ihr dann unbedingt, dass ich was dazu sage? Das ist für mich dann irgendwie nicht so ganz logisch. Sorry, das war ein sehr langer Feedback-Teil. Trotzdem natürlich per se könnt ihr wirklich über alles diskutieren. Es ist natürlich muss am Ende das sowieso Max entscheiden, nicht ich. Das war nur der eine Punkt, wo ich dann interagiert habe. Es ist vielleicht manchmal auch schwierig, sowas immer alles nur digital zu machen und nicht die Personen vor sich zu haben. Generell liebe ich aber die Rasenfunk-Community, liebe den Discord, liebe euch Kommentierende da draußen und freue mich immer über Feedback. Und natürlich an der Stelle die Erinnerung, der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt werbe-, Paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren euch uns ausschließlich durch eure Unterstützung. Mehr Infos gibt es dazu unter rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Da könnt ihr, falls ihr es noch nicht seid, SupporterInnen werden oder vielleicht sogar euren Beitrag noch ein bisschen hochschalten, wenn ihr nämlich vor allem gesehen hat, was vor allem Max ja in den letzten Wochen hier rausgehauen hat, an Tribünen gesprochen und Co und was alles noch so kommt. Und es ist Royalzeit, geht wieder los. Also wenn ihr sagt, das Auto lasse ich momentan stehen, die, weiß ich nicht, 50 Euro für eine halbe Dankladung, die investiere ich lieber in den Rasenfunk, dann go for it. Sonst wisst ihr, es ist gestern oder in der Nacht zu heute, wir haben jetzt Montagabend, ist die Besprechung des Bundesligaspieltags der Männer entschieden. Logischerweise gibt es kein Äquivalent zur Bundesliga der Frauen, denn morgen und Samstag stehen die Spiele, Länderspiele gegen Österreich an. Dazu erscheint dann in der Nacht auf Sonntag eine Folge. Gegebenenfalls gibt es noch einen Schwerpunkt bei den Männern, aber die Royalezeit steht an und die Frage ist, wie viel mehr das gerade noch bringt. Monolog Eva, Part 2, Ende. Dann können wir uns nämlich von unten nach oben schauen und wir gucken auf das Spiel Elbersberg gegen Schalke 04. Letztere gewinnen das direkte Duell gegen Elbersberg mit 2 zu 1. Dabei geht die SVE schon nach 4 Minuten durch Schnellwache in Führung. Wortwitze, let's go. Allerdings kann El Fawzi in der 48. Minute den Ausgleich erzielen, bei der Schalke aufgrund einer Verletzung von Elbersbergs Keidel in Überzahl ist. Kurz nach Wiederantritt sind ein Die nach einem vermeintlichen faulen Petkoff, die gelb-rote Karte, die hinterher für viele Diskussionen sorgen wird. Schalke kann dennoch 2 Minuten später durch Silla in Führung gehen und bleibt danach defensiv stabil. Elbersberg kann den Ausgleich nicht mehr passieren und muss eben so einen kleinen Dämpfer im Ausstiegskampf hinnehmen. Am Montag wird übrigens dann noch klar, Schalke hat mit seinem Einspruch, Erfolg nie da ist Sperre, wird zurückgenommen. Anna, lass uns zuerst auf die SVE schauen. Platz 4 ist es momentan, 52 Punkte. Wir bewegen uns in andere Tabellenregionen, 49 zu 32 Tore, 15 Siege, 7 Unentschieden, 7 Niederlagen. Vom Tabelle ist allerdings nur Platz 11 momentan, sowie viele andere Teams, 2 Sieger, 1 Unentschieden, 2 Niederlage. Nach dem Sieg gegen Bielefeld vor der Länderspielpause folgte jetzt noch ein Unentschieden gegen Hannover und eben die Niederlage gegen Schalke. Würdest du mir zustimmen, dass es vielleicht ein Spiel war, wo am Ende Schalkes Effizienz liegt? Also vielleicht genau die Effizienz, die in der Partie gegen Hannover Elbersberg auch schon gefehlt hat?
Wahrscheinlich schon, ja. Ich bin ein bisschen überrascht durch dieses, ich finde, Nachlassen ist eigentlich ein zu starkes Wort, weil ich nicht den Eindruck habe, dass das unbedingt zu der Intensität der Spiele passt, die Elbersberg abliefert, die ich super hoch finde. Das sind immer unglaublich konzentrierte Leistungen. Ich finde, dass ein sehr intensives Coaching, das da stattfindet, ohne dass das irgendwie diesen Fokus auf sich zieht, den ich manchmal bei Kohfeldt habe, wo ich finde, dass er da wirklich sehr präsent ist. Es fällt mir gerade schwer, in Worte zu fassen. Ich finde das eigentlich alles sehr gradlinig auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite. Flauen gerade die Ergebnisse ab und sie sind jetzt noch ein Stück davon entfernt, den Anschluss an die Spitze zu verlieren. Ich hatte zwischenzeitlich in der Saison hätte ich einiges darauf gesetzt, dass die sich da oben so richtig dörflich festsetzen, weil sie sich von keinem reinquatschen lassen, weil sie keine krasse Presse haben, weil sie ein viel ruhigeres Umfeld haben als Schalke oder Hannover, dass die einfach ihr Ding durchziehen und dann als erster oder zweiter souverän aufsteigen. Und dieses, finde ich schon gerade, vielleicht irgendwie Delle oder kleines Low, überrascht mich ein bisschen, weil das irgendwie auch relativ lautlos passiert. Und aus dem werde ich nicht so richtig schlau. Vielleicht ist es mit fehlender Effizienz, wie du das gerade gesagt hast, tatsächlich ganz gut beschrieben auf der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite. Wenn ich mich jetzt auch gegen, also in dem Spiel gegen 96 würde ich sagen, trifft das auf jeden Fall, nee, trifft das tatsächlich eher nicht so zu, weil Hannover super spielstark gewesen ist. Elbersberg kriegt einen Elfmeter eher geschenkt als verdient zugesprochen, verwandelt den und fährt dann mit einem verhältnismäßig glücklichen 1-1 nach Hause. Jetzt gegen Schalke, vielleicht war das einfach wirklich, denn doch diese eine Nummer zu groß als Gegner. Also ich glaube, dass Schalke total gebrannt hat. Also mit vielen Verletzungen, Sperren etc., sprechen wir gleich noch in Ruhe drüber, hatte ich das Gefühl, dass die sich vorgenommen haben, uns spuckt hier keiner in die Suppe und wir ziehen das hier eiskalt durch. Und dass das irgendwie ein Level von Konzentriertheit war, das in der Liga wahrscheinlich tatsächlich seinesgleichen sucht und Ebersberg jetzt gerade so ein bisschen an seine oberen Grenzen stößt in den letzten beiden Spielen in Hannover mit dieser titzhaften Sortiertheit. Und Schalke jetzt zu Hause. Vielleicht ist es doch dieser Aufstieg noch ein bisschen zu früh.
Also um es ein bisschen perspektivisch zu setzen, man muss dazu sagen, dass ähnliche Punkteausbeute bzw. genau die gleiche Punkteausbeute gab es in der Hinrunde eben auch. Also da gab es eben auch eine Niederlage gegen Schalke, eine Knappe, ein 2 zu 2 gegen Hannover. Also per se, da kann man jetzt vielleicht davon reden, okay, vielleicht fehlte da so ein bisschen Anführungsstrichen die Weiterentwicklung oder man kann einfach sagen, gut, sie können halt trotzdem mithalten mit diesen Teams, die ja doch auf dem Platz dann ganz, ganz andere Qualitäten mitbringen. Also ich fand, ich würde dir so ein bisschen fast sogar in der, beim Hannover-Spiel vielleicht in Teilen widersprechen. Also ich fand das, ja da fast, also Hannover hatte den spielerisch besseren Ansatz, aber ich fand Elversberg trotzdem nicht chancenlos. Also sie machen am Ende nur das Tor durch den Elfmeter und da gehe ich auch mit, der war durchaus schmeichelhaft. Ich fand das trotzdem aber, also mein Problem ist glaube ich eher so, ihnen ist so ein bisschen das, was sie im Spiel gegen Bielefeld zum Beispiel noch hatten, diese offensive Leichtigkeit abhandgekommen. Also sie waren ja über lange Zeit eigentlich auch das offensiv stärkste Team der Liga. Da habe ich eher so das Gefühl, dass es ihnen so ein bisschen abhanden gekommen. Diese Spielfreude auch eigentlich, also wie gesagt, gut gegen Bielefeld hast du eigentlich gesehen, was sie für eine Wucht entwickeln können, wenn sie führen. Und das hat mir hier bei dem 1-0 so ein bisschen gefehlt. Natürlich muss man da aber auch trotzdem mal mit reinrechnen, wir reden gleich noch über Schalke. Es ist wirklich brutal schwer diesen, das haben sie schon beim 1-0 sehr, sehr schön. Also ich finde das sehr schön rausgespielt, das 1-0 mit Schnellbach hat dann am Ende, der vollendet. Aber das ist mir irgendwann so ein bisschen abhanden gekommen, glaube ich, in dem Spiel. Sonst muss man sagen, es wird, glaube ich, also da schon mal nach vorne zu blicken. Du hast jetzt eben noch die direkten Duelle gegen Darmstadt und Paderborn. Empfängst du jetzt erst, glaube ich, zu Hause Karlsruhe und dann eben auswärts bei Darmstadt und zu Hause gegen Paderborn. Also ich glaube, da reicht es halt nicht, dass du, also beziehungsweise gegen Paderborn hast du gewonnen in der Hinrunde gegen Darmstadt unentschieden gespielt. Da bleibt dann halt so ein bisschen die Frage, wie gehen diese Partien aus? Surprise. Ob du es da dann halt schaffst, vielleicht die so ein bisschen auf deine Spielweise zu ziehen. Also auf das, was du eigentlich willst. Das heißt, also ich verstehe schon, was du mit Delle meinst. Wie gesagt, das sieht jetzt halt gerade einfach nicht so gut aus. Du hast halt 6 zu 6 Tore, 2 Sieger in unentschieden zwei Niederlagen. Das ist irgendwie so ein Hühn-Hot auch gerade. Also dir fehlt so ein bisschen die Konstanz drin. Und ich glaube, das ist eher das größere Problem, dass du dir das halt, wenn du aufsteigen willst, gar nicht erlauben kannst. Gleichzeitig sage ich es auch gerne nochmal. Da ist dann immer die Frage, ist der mangelnde Druck gut oder ist der mangelnde Druck schlecht? Und ich glaube, man muss da auch ganz, ganz wichtig sagen, viel größer wird ja sowieso die Frage sein, wie geht der Elwasberger Weg weiter? Denn wir wissen alle, Ole Boke ist mit sofortiger Wirkung zu Borussia Dortmund gewechselt, Christian Weber ist der neue Sportdirektor, ehemals bei Fortuna Düsseldorf. Da bleibt für mich tatsächlich auf lange Perspektive eher die Frage, also wir haben uns alle, ich sage es zum hunderttausendsten Mal, wie damals gefragt, wie werden sie Horst Steffen überleben und so wie Elvesbergs Konzept ist, mit natürlich auch viel mit Leihspielern arbeiten und darüber ein Konzept entwickeln, über die Art und Weise, was man für einen Fußball spielen lassen will. Das hängt dann natürlich in Zukunft auch sehr davon ab, wer eben auf diesem Sportdirektor posten sitzt, wir wissen jetzt, wer das ist. Aber, ja, also ich weiß nicht, wie ihr das seht. Dass man da jetzt nicht das große Risiko gibt, verstehe ich auch. Aber erstmal fand ich, in Anführungszeichen, das ein leichtes Downgrade im Vergleich zu Olebrook. Leichtes, ja? Ja, keine bösen Kommentare, aber.
Ja, aber ich finde es schwierig zu bewerten. Also gerade wenn ich jetzt an Düsseldorf zurückdenke, ich meine, über die haben wir ja schon ein bisschen gesprochen. Und wenn wir jetzt schauen, was bei Düsseldorf so passiert ist und was zum Beispiel da die Anspruchshaltung war, mit der man in diese Saison ist und auch diesen großen Umbruch. Klaus Alofs und Weber zusammen, so keiner mehr da jetzt. Das ist ja auch irgendwie bezeichnet, dass das halt gar nicht so funktioniert hat. Ja, bin ich gespannt, wie das jetzt matcht an der Stelle. Und gleichzeitig ist Elbersberg so ein Verein, der mich immer wieder total überrascht. Also ich hätte vor dieser Saison im Leben nicht drauf gewettet, dass die so oben mitspielen und dass das so... Also hätte ich im Leben nicht gedacht, also was da ja alles passiert ist, was da auch alles an Veränderungen, an Abgängen zu verkaufen, weil ich mein Haussteffner, das ist auch gerade schon erwähnt, aber das finde ich total schwierig zu bewerten. Also das ist für mich so ein bisschen, ich will jetzt nicht sagen eine Wundertüte, aber Elbersberg habe ich schon so oft falsch eingeschätzt. Wir alle. Ja, da bin ich wirklich so... Wir alle. Ich habe gar keine Ahnung von nix. So, das denke ich immer wieder bei Elbersberg. Auch, um vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen konkreter auf das Beispiel jetzt gegen Schalke zu gehen, die ersten Minuten war ich total geplättet, wie Elbersberg da aufgetreten ist im positiven Sinne. Auch, wie schnell das 1-0 fiel. Und was das für ein Gesicht war, dass die das nicht so durchziehen konnten und dass das nicht geklappt hat, das würde ich gar nicht so sehr auf... Elbersberg war irgendwie zu schwach und also diese Delle, sondern da kam halt gerade Schalke und auf welcher Welle die irgendwie gerade reiten. So habe ich das Gefühl, da kann gar nichts passieren und die haut nix um. Dass ich das Gefühl habe, das lag gar nicht so sehr an Elbersberg, sondern viel mehr an Schalke. Deswegen jetzt die letzten Spiele, klar, das Restprogramm, du hast das gerade angeteased, geht auch noch gegen direkte Konkurrenten und wird irgendwie spannend. Aber ich traue mir nicht so eine richtige Bewertung jetzt zu, auch was jetzt diese neue Stelle angeht.
Anna?
Ich finde es cool, dass die so Bock haben und dass auch danach formuliert wird, wie genervt die sind über die Niederlage gegen Schalke, dass die da schon sich was anderes vorgenommen hatten. Und das finde ich cool, dass du da aus einer enorm sportlichen Qualität, die du wirklich auf eine überhaupt nicht selbstverständliche Art und Weise jetzt in der zweiten Saison auf so konstant hohem Niveau hältst und ja auch nicht, wie es eigentlich oft typisch ist in der 2. Liga, durch so Phasen-Amplituden gehst. Dass du sagst, boah krass, vier Niederlagen, aber dafür auch wieder fünf Siege, sondern dass du eigentlich wirklich da einfach oben bleibst ohne große Ausschläge nach oben oder unten, trotz dieser großen Veränderungen, die du personell verkraften musstest. Zum einen, aber ja auch mental verkraftet nicht jedes Team eine Pleite in der Relegation so easy, da oben wieder anzugriffen. Auch Düsseldorf ist es irgendwie dann langfristig nicht besonders gut bekommen beispielsweise. Und jetzt wollte ich jetzt mal ich den Faden so ein bisschen verloren. Ach ja, genau. Wir haben eben in einem anderen Kontext, genau KSC haben wir darüber gesprochen, was ist da eigentlich die Idee. Und ich habe bei Elversberg das Gefühl, dass die Idee total klar ist. Also zum einen eben dieses Leihspieler-Konzept und auch darauf wirklich zu setzen. Und das finde ich, finde ich phänomenal und etwas, was glaube ich außerhalb eines solchen Standorts nur schwer zu vermitteln ist, aber eine hohe sportliche Qualität ganz offenbar mit sich trägt. Weil ja andere Vereine sagen, nein, wir möchten nicht nur mit Leihspielern arbeiten. Die sollen vielleicht punktuell Qualität dazu bringen, von der wir dann phasenweise profitieren. Aber wir möchten eigentlich im Grundsatz unseren Kader, unseren Spieler, unsere Identität, denn wir sind immer die Coolsten und wir brauchen Treue und wir brauchen Loyalität und so weiter. Also diese ganzen großen moral aufgeladenen Worte. Und das irgendwie umzukehren und zu sagen, unser Konzept ist die Anleihe von so hoher Qualität und die wird einfach immer wieder ausgetauscht. Worin das mündet, finde ich total– also weiß ich nicht genau, vielleicht weiß das eine von euch, ob das Sprungbrett ist dahin, dass du eben so wie Hoffenheim dann irgendwann deinen eigenen Kader hast, um Bundesliga zu spielen oder ob das einfach nachhaltige Strategie ist. Weil ich mir das zum Beispiel als sportliche Idee für die Kaderzusammenstellung jetzt in Braunschweig zum Beispiel nicht vorstellen kann. Das könntest du kommunikativ schlecht aufrechterhalten. These.
Ja, die Frage ist dann natürlich, glaube ich, schon immer. Elversberg kommt halt im Gegensatz, ich glaube vor allem zu unserem Verein, aber auch zu deinem Verein, Lisa, nicht aus so einer finanziellen Notwendigkeit her, dass die Spieler, die Jungspieler, die du weiterentwickelst, für Geld verkaufen musst. Also ich glaube, du kriegst es schon an vielen Standorten vermittelt, dass du dir davon eben deine finanzielle Stabilität erarbeiten musst, aber du bekommst es eben nicht an vielen Standorten vermittelt, dass du ja per se, also außer es ist beispielsweise bei Ebno Talib, wo du das ja schon auch finanziell gemerkt hast dann, dass es per se natürlich nicht funktioniert, dass du irgendwie als Talent weiterentwickeln giltst. Das glaube ich schon, das darf man da nicht so komplett. Also natürlich ist am Ende auch die SV Elversberg in einer Weise ein Wirtschaftsunternehmen, die Profit abwerfen will in irgendeiner Art und Weise, das ist mir auch schon bewusst, aber es kommt natürlich immer, woher kommst du finanziell und das ist eben was, wo wir natürlich bei unseren drei Vereinen beispielsweise sehen, da hast du jetzt nicht so die Freiheiten, dass du dir jetzt mal sagen kannst. Also ich glaube schon, dass man das dann nicht ganz unbeachtet sehen kann. Daher ist ja eben meine Frage, ob Christian Weber das so fortsetzt. Also er hat ja relativ kurz Vita bisher, er war Scout bei Fortuna Düsseldorf und dann eben drei Jahre bis zum 15. und 12. Sportdirektor. Es ist natürlich jetzt anders, weil er eben keinen Klaus-Alofs über sich sitzen hat. Also er hat schon eine andere Machtposition, in Anführungszeichen. Also er hat einfach eine andere Verantwortung. Das war halt so der Punkt, wo ich gesagt habe, ich gehe jetzt nicht davon aus, dass er das alles auf links umkrempelt. Das wird Elversberg nicht wollen. Aber da bin ich eben sehr, sehr gespannt, ob sie das schaffen, diesen Weg eben fortzusetzen mit dieser Idee im Hinterkopf, mit der Identität, ob das alles so klappt. Würde ich fast sagen, die gleichen Fragen stellt sich der eine oder andere Elversberger, die Elversbergerin auch. Also das ist eben meine Frage. Aber das werden wir sowieso im Sommer alles sehen. Ich gehe auch davon aus, die größten Stellschrauben, die hat Ole Burk sowieso schon gestellt für die kommende Saison. Auch wenn es natürlich schwierig ist, wenn du noch nicht weißt, in welcher Liga du spielst. Aber ich gehe fast davon aus, dass es da schon so ein paar Stellschrauben einfach gibt, die er dir auch anzupfen kann. Und man muss eben sagen, Christian Biber war eben auch vorher Scout. Er bringt natürlich auch so ein bisschen diesen, ich sag mal, erstmal vielleicht mehr operativen Teil noch mit, den du als Sportdirektor eben auch brauchst. Aber es ist sowieso, wie gesagt, es ist alle Spekulation. Ich gehe aber sonst auch mit euren Beobachtungen mit. Wie gesagt, ich finde, sonst kann man sich Elbersbergspiel auch sehr, sehr gut angucken. Aber da wird eben die Frage sein, ob es eben am Ende reicht, um da am Ende dran zu bleiben. Und ich glaube, dann können wir, also gefühlt in keinem, keiner Partie wie in dieser Partie bisher, konnte man die eine Seite nicht analysieren, um immer mal wieder schon auf die andere Seite zu gucken. Und diese andere Seite, das ist eben der FC Schalke 04. Er steht auf Platz 1, hat 58 Punkte, 41 zu 25 Tore, 17 Siege, 7 Unentschieden und 5 Niederlagen. Auf der Formtabelle ist man Platz 2, 3 Siege, 2 Unentschieden, wird im Knapp überholt vom SC Paderborn, haben aber beide 11 Punkte aus den letzten 5 Spielen gesammelt. Schalke ist weiterhin die Mannschaft mit den wenigsten Gegentoren, das sind 0,9 pro Spiel. Elversberg übrigens auf Platz 2 mit 1,1. Man blieb in dieser Saison zwölfmal ohne Gegentor. Übrigens genau wie. Wisst ihr, welche Mannschaft in der 2. Liga auch zwölfmal ohne Gegentor blieb? Einfach mal.
Nicht Nürnberg.
Ich hätte es tatsächlich so direkt nicht erwartet. Es ist Hertha BSC.
Oh, okay.
Das fand ich schon sehr, sehr spannend, ehrlich gesagt. Man hat die dritthöchste Klärungsrate pro Spiel. Also sie liegt bei 31,3. 909 Klärungen. Nur Fürth und Kiel haben mehr. Und da sieht man ja schon einen sehr großen Unterschied in den Tabellen. Und man muss eben sagen, trotz Verletzungs-Sorgen, also ohne Cartridge und ohne Dzeko, außer dem Gelb-Sperren bei Karaman und Aihahn für die Gummi und Sanchez ins Spiel gekommen sind, gewinnt man dieses Spiel. Und man muss ja, glaube ich, ihr habt eben schon mal gesagt, bei Schalke, da hat man so eine Bissigkeit gemerkt, vor allem ja eigentlich nach diesem unberechtigten Platzverweis, das muss man ja einfach sagen. Es ist ja umgekehrt. Petkov trifft einen Daje und nicht umgekehrt. Und trotzdem schafft man es nach dieser Unterzeit sehr, sehr schnell, das 2.1 zu erzielen und dann ja wirklich das zu machen. Schalke am besten schafft nämlich, sich ja auf ihre defensive Stabilität zu bewegen. Lisa, wir haben mal Anfang des Jahres so ein bisschen provokant nachgefragt, ob es bei Schalke vielleicht doch noch mal so eine Delle gibt, ob vielleicht die Euphorie am Ende, ja, ihn so ein bisschen selber das Messer in den Rücken rammt. Ich glaube, wir können sagen, wie bei so vielen in dieser Saison, lagen wir da ziemlich falsch.
Ja, würde ich jetzt mal so unterschreiben an der Stelle. Ja, ich finde es beeindruckend, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Also gerade bei großen Traditionsvereinen, wie Schalke das ja auch einer ist, geht das ja auch schnell, dass es dann mal kippt, wenn vielleicht das ein oder andere Spiel nicht so läuft, wenn es irgendwie Rückschläge gibt, wenn du Verletzungen hast, wenn auch Dinge einfach mal gegen dich laufen. Und ich würde wirklich sagen, in Elbersberg ist erstmal einiges gegen Schalke gelaufen. Aber ich habe das ja schon angeteased von meiner kleinen Antwort zu Elbersberg. Die wirft halt gerade nichts um. Also man hat das Gefühl so, das ist zumindest mein Gefühl, wenn ich gerade Schalke gucke, da kann kommen, was will, das haut die nicht um. Die ziehen, wie jetzt hier in Elbersberg, eher noch mehr raus und haben richtig Bock. Ich will auch gar nicht wieder mit Mentalität. Ich glaube, das kennen wir alle und das haben wir auch schon zu oft an zu vielen Stellen gehört. Aber das ist für mich gerade so der Inbegriff von, da stimmt einfach so viel sportlich, was da an Qualität drinsteckt. Selbst wenn du hast die Ausfälle ja gerade aufgezählt, dass sie auch das auf der einen Seite wegstecken und sportlich gesehen, ja. Aber ich finde gerade so dieses Teamgefüge, da stimmt einfach so viel insgesamt zwischen Trainer, Mannschaft, Fans. Und das ist dann so eine klassische Situation von, du schwätzt von Erfolgserlebnis zu Erfolgserlebnis, wenn man die Bilder gesehen hat nach Abwurf. Also ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, da wurde der Aufstieg ja schon gefeiert, aber gefühlt wurde da der Aufstieg schon gefeiert. Guck ein bisschen neidisch dahin und würde mir das auch mal wieder wünschen. Auf der anderen Seite macht es auch einfach Bock. Also das muss ich so ehrlich schon auch sagen. Für mich Schalke so ein Verein, der einfach ganz klein in die 1. Liga gehörte, wo ich jetzt mit Blick auf Tabelle und Restprogramme und so schon sagen würde, ja, man darf sich jetzt noch nicht ausruhen. Aber ich sehe da jetzt gar nicht mehr so große Gefahren, um es vielleicht so zu formulieren und freue mich da.
Ja, man muss glaube ich auch sagen, also zwischenzeitlich mit diesem 1 zu 0 für Elbersberg hatten die sich an Schalke auch vorbei geschoben. Jetzt hat man eben 6 Punkte Abstand, beziehungsweise waren gleich– nee, da waren vorbeigezogen bei besseres Torverhältnis, so rum, Punkt gleich, aber eben vorbeigezogen. Und jetzt hat man eben 6 Punkte Abstand auf Elbersberg, 5 Punkte auf Hannover 96 auf Platz 3, einen auf Paderborn. Also es war auch schon wichtig, dieses Spiel, glaube ich, zu gewinnen. Was ich da ganz interessant finde, finde diese Streuung, die wir im Abstiegskampf in den Torverhältnissen haben, die haben wir da oben gar nicht mal so. Also das finde ich auch schon sehr interessant. Also ich mache es der Vollständigkeit, aber auch gehe ich das auch einmal durch. Wir haben Schalke auf Platz 1, 58 Punkte, Tordifferenz ist 16, 41 zu 25 Tore Paderborn, 57 Punkte, 31 zu 34, äh, 51 zu 34, Tordifferenz von 17, Hannover 96, 53 Punkte, 49 zu 35, 14 Tordifferenz, Elbersberg, äh, 52 Tore, 49 zu 32, also 17 Tore und dann Darmstadt, da würde ich dann den Cut machen, 50 Punkte, ähm, 50 zu 34 Tore, 16 Tordifferenz. Also was wir da unten haben, dass wir Punkte technisch sehr beieinander sind, Torverhältnismäßig sehr weit oder viele Vereine mit gleichen Punkten, unterschiedliche Torverhältnisse, ist da eben schon so ein bisschen anders. Noch, in Anführungszeichen, ähm, aber da siehst du eben den klaren Cut zu Hertha BSC, die dann halt wirklich in Anführungszeichen nur um 9 Punkte oder um 9 Tore positives Torverhältnis haben. Ähm, also du siehst da eben, um so ein bisschen Punkt rund zu machen, dass es schon sehr, sehr wichtig war, dieses Spiel zu gewinnen. Man muss da sagen, ähm, nachdem man eben gegen Hannover und Darmstadt nur unentschieden spielen konnte, war es, glaube ich, auch wichtig, den Sieg jetzt trotzdem zu holen. Also es gab ja schon in Anführungszeichen so ein bisschen, im Gegensatz eben zu der Hinrunde, da so, dass man dem Gegner da so ein bisschen die Chance gegeben hat, an sich näher ranzukommen. Aber da muss man jetzt eben sagen, das haben sie dann gegen Elvesberg anders gemacht. Und sie haben eben die Möglichkeit, wenn wir eben drauf gucken, sie spielen dann als nächstes gegen Preußen Münster. Und dann kommt wirklich, gleich kann man in Anführungszeichen ein bisschen sagen, dass die Partie, die frühzeitig so ein bisschen die Meisterschaft entscheiden könnte. Wir werden darüber reden in zwei Wochen. Die Partie gegen den SC Paderborn. Also ich glaube, das wird einfach so ein bisschen der Vorentscheid, wer da vielleicht in den Mai hinein die Nase ein bisschen vorn hat. Aber also das ist wirklich der einzige Verein, wo ich jetzt auch aufgrund des Restprogramms Münster, Paderborn, Düsseldorf, Nürnberg, Braunschweig, doch aufgrund der Stabilität, die sie mit sich bringen und die ganzen– also wir haben bei Fortuna Düsseldorf darüber geredet, man darf sich nicht immer dahinter ausruhen, Verletzungen und so. Und da muss ich sagen, da muss– klar, es ist was ganz anderes, ob du auf Platz 1 oder unten auf Platz 16 oder so stehst. Aber das hat mir zum Beispiel nach dem Karlsruh-Spiel sehr, sehr gut gefallen, wie er da auch gesagt hat, ey, ich habe Spieler, alle Spieler im Kader, auf die kann ich mich erstmal verlassen. Und ich glaube, selbst in Sanchez, der seit der Partie, glaube ich, gegen Elbersberg in der Hinrunde eben nicht mehr in der Startelf stand, da konntest du hier in die Startelf stellen. Und das ist dann natürlich auch, ja, einfach nochmal ein Zeichen für die mannschaftliche Geschlossenheit, die eben absolut intakt ist. Und wo du einfach merkst, da wird dann eben auch nach dem Rückstand, nach der Unterzahl, wird halt da jeder Schritt gegangen. Sehr beeindruckend, finde ich.
Ja, definitiv. Also ich hatte phasenweise etwas den Eindruck, dass Schalke, ist ja auch nicht schlimm, aber sehr so das macht, was es halt braucht und sich dabei aber auch nicht verausgabt. Jetzt aber im Schlussspurt zeigt, dass es völlig okay ist, so zu agieren, weil sie eben einfach wirklich noch zwei, drei Gänge in der Hinterhund hatten, in die sie hochschalten können, ganz offensichtlich. Und Eva finde auch genau das, das ist ein bisschen das Gegenbeispiel zu Klagen über Schiedsrichter und Verletzungen, da einfach wirklich durchzuziehen, weil es wäre auch legitim gewesen irgendwie, du holst Jeko in der Winterpause, der verletzt sich in der Länderspielpause, darauf hinzuweisen, dass das irgendwie schmerzhaft ist, oder dieser Ausfall nicht zu kompensieren, oder wie auch immer. Und jetzt da eben in unverdienter Unterzahl, so ein Top-Spiel abzuliefern, ist einfach phänomenal. Ich habe es wirklich nicht mit Schalke, aber da kann man wenig dran finden, was man aussetzen könnte. Das finde ich echt sehr, sehr stark und absolut uneingeschränkt verdiente Tabellenführung.
Das kann man, glaube ich, dann wirklich auch einfach mal mit Miron Muslitsch und ja generell auch Frau Bauman und Co. einfach nochmal attestieren, was wir vielleicht an anderen Standorten nicht gesehen haben. Aber da gibt es halt trotzdem eine Weiterentwicklung und eben ja auch so eine Art von Plan B, was wir eben an anderen Stellen vielleicht nicht unbedingt haben. Aber den muss man eben schon eine gute Reaktion auf Rückschläge auch irgendwie attestieren. Und ich hätte es tatsächlich nicht gedacht, dass sie so noch mal in diesen Saisonentspurt reingehen. Klar, wir wissen auch da noch nicht, was passiert in den letzten fünf Spielen. Aber sie sind eben in einer für diese Liga durchaus komfortableren Ausgangslage, als man vielleicht erwartet hat. Vorsichtig gedacht. Und ich muss weiterhin einfach sagen, ich finde die Art und Weise von Miron Muslić, das passt einfach zu Schalke. Also der hat es, glaube ich, geschafft, wird es mal wirklich ein bisschen kitschig ausgedrückt, eine ganze Reihe an Generationen hinter sich zu versammeln, die Schalke 04 zwischendurch verloren hatte. Und das macht er nicht mit dem allerschönsten Fußball der Liga. Aber ich weiß halt noch, ich habe vor der Saison gesagt, Schalke muss den Ernst der Lage realisieren und dass sie eben nicht gegen Real Madrid in der Champions League spielen, sondern einfach erstmal ums blanke Überleben in der 2. Liga oder ganz dringend aufpassen müssen. Und man muss da ja einfach noch mal sagen und vielleicht so ein bisschen den Rückschluss auf Christian Eichner am Anfang zu ziehen. Auch wenn natürlich Schalke nie in der Situation war, der jetzt in Karlsruhe war oder Amine Bielefeld in dieser Saison. Aber du schaffst mit Miron Muslice auch eine Identität für den Klub. Und das ist etwas, was Schalke ganz, ganz lange und zwar nicht diese klassische ihr haben Aloha und Kumpel und dies und das, sondern du schaffst halt trotzdem erstmal eine Identität von einem, von Wohlfühlsein in diesem Verein. Und das ist eben etwas, was Schalke ganz, ganz lange und ich glaube, dass das übertreibe ich auch nicht wirklich gefehlt hat. Und das ist für mich auch, da bin ich mal sehr gespannt, wenn, wie sie sich dann in der Bundesliga schlagen, weil wir eben in der Vergangenheit immer wieder gesehen haben, wenn du jemanden hast, hinter dem du dich versammeln kannst. Das kann schiefgehen, wie im Fall von Leverknecht in zwei Fällen so. Aber du kannst eben auch sehen, dass es klappen kann. Klar, Miron Muslitsch ist noch lange nicht auf dem gleichen Weg wie Frank Schmidt. Ich glaube, da sind wir uns schon alle einig. Eine Saison reicht dafür nicht. Aber er hat eben jetzt schon einen Status, den eben, wie gesagt, ganz lange kein Schalke-Trainer mehr vor ihm hatte. Tja, schauen wir mal, was das wird. Und dann leite ich nochmal über und zwar zu einer Mannschaft, wo man eigentlich auch dachte, sie befinden sich in einer sehr komfortablen Situation im Ausstiegskampf. Die Redes von Darmstadt 98, die mussten am Samstagabend die erste Heimliederlage der Saison hinnehmen. Gegen Hannover 96. In diesem Topspiel dominiert 96 einen Tag vor seinem 130-jährigen Geburtstag, den SVD regelrecht Neubauer in der 14. und Torderson in der 55. Minuten schießen, die Hannoveraner auf Platz 3. Allerdings musste auch Hannover dreimal verletzungsbedingt wechseln. Kellmann kam in der 20. Minute für Pichlard, Gieter in halb so zwei für Nawrocki und Torschütze. Torderson musste in der 73. Minute durch Matsuda ersetzt werden. Wir blicken zunächst auf Darmstadt 98. Die sind jetzt auf Platz 5 abgerutscht, haben 50 Punkte, 50 zu 34 Tore, 13 Siege, 11 unentschieden, fünf Niederlagen in der Formtabelle. Da ist man inzwischen auch auf Platz 14 abgerutscht. Nur ein Sieg in den letzten fünf Spielen, zwei unentschieden, zwei Niederlagen. Nach der Niederlage gegen Bielefeld am vergangenen Wochenende, die neben der, ja, ich würde schon sagen, zumindestens für Kläfisch fragt, für den Gelb-Sperre und eben noch für Liedberg eben auch ein Dämpfer im Aufstiegskampf bedeutete, Cofeld dann Papella, Schmidt und Lakenmacher starten lassen, Richter tatsächlich auf der Bank. Vor dieser Niederlage gegen Bielefeld gab es eben die Unentschieden gegen Schalke und Magdeburg. Lisa, ich würde mal bei dir anfangen. Im Forum, wo so ein bisschen diskutiert, wird Darmstadt 98 jetzt doch nervös, nachdem man ja doch so ein bisschen ausgerufen hatte, es geht jetzt doch dann um den Ausstieg.
Ja, du hast die Zahlen ja gerade ganz gut zusammengefasst. Ich finde, das ist so das klassische Beispiel von, die lassen jetzt Federn. Also das, was Anna so ganz gut beschrieben hat bei Schalke, die schaffen es jetzt noch, den Gang hochzuschalten oder die schaffen es jetzt noch, auch Spiele, die vielleicht nicht für sie laufen, noch zu drehen und da einfach dann nicht diese Rückschläge zu bekommen. Das ist, glaube ich, genau das Gegenteil jetzt bei Darmstadt, was wir so ein bisschen beobachten können an der Stelle. Mich hat das ehrlicherweise echt überrascht, wie das gegen Hannover gelaufen ist. Das war jetzt ja noch nicht mal– also du kannst verlieren und du kannst irgendwie knapp verlieren, unglücklich verlieren. Ich glaube, die Spiele kennen wir alle, wo man am Ende dann sitzt, naja, es ist irgendwie blöd gelaufen. Aber das fand ich schon in der Art und Weise überraschend. Also das hatte ich so nicht auf dem Zettel, ehrlicherweise. Nicht nur, weil Darmstadt so heimstark ist. Ich weiß gerade gar nicht, ob du den Fact gebroppt hast, aber erste Heimpleite seit elf Monaten, das fand ich auch eine krasse Zahl. Und so wie das Spiel dann lief und das, was da alles irgendwie gefehlt hat, das hätte ich so nicht erwartet. Ich fand irgendwie schon auch bezeichnend, du hast es ja gerade auch so ein bisschen angeteasst, man hat da jetzt schon deutlich nach oben geblickt, dass auch wirklich so der Frust sehr, sehr, sehr rauskam. Es ist ja jetzt noch nichts verloren und so. Also ich verstehe das ein Stück weit gleichzeitig. Da war ich dann noch überrascht, wie angepisst alle da waren. Ein Stück weit, ja klar, muss man angepisst sein. Das hat mich dann doch so ein bisschen, ja ich weiß gar nicht, ob es verwundert das richtige Wort ist. Natürlich ist man nicht happy in der Niederlage, aber so die Härte, die da irgendwie auch drin steckte in dem ein oder anderen Satz, auch gerade weil Hannover natürlich gefeiert hat und dass das natürlich dann auch nicht so gut da ankam, verstehe ich alles, aber könnte so ein bisschen den Schluss zulassen mit so, ja man hat da jetzt vielleicht auch ein bisschen Aufstiegsangst, wenn man es psychologisch irgendwie einsortieren will. Aber ja, also ist jetzt für mich, also hatte ich so nicht kommen sehen in der Art und Weise und spricht jetzt für mich gerade nicht so sehr viel für Darmstadt, wenn ich mich auf Top 2, 3, also ehrlicherweise Top 2, ist ja schon ein kleiner Abstand, du hast es gesagt, bis Paderborn auf 2, 7 Punkte, bis auf Schalke 8 Punkte. Hannover, klar, das waren jetzt die Big Points, ich glaube, da können wir ja gleich nochmal ein bisschen genauer drüber sprechen, aber ein bisschen aufstiegsflatter oder wie hattest du es gerade genannt, würde ich schon unterschreiben an der Stelle.
Anna, wie siehst du das?
Ich glaube, dass Darmstadt 98 ergebnismäßig absolut überperformt hat in dieser Saison. Ich finde, die haben oft– spielerisch schon überzeugt– Tore gemacht nach Standards oder nach so, okay, what the fuck, warum macht er denn jetzt diese Tortore?
Und ich glaube, wenn du aufhörst, diese Tore zu machen, bei denen einfach in 98 Prozent der Fälle kein Tor rausspringt, dann kriegst du ein Problem. Also Isaac Lidberg hat– das war, glaube ich, in der Hinrunde hatte er irgendwie orientiert an seinen Expected Goals– vier Tore mehr gemacht, als es überhaupt wahrscheinlich gewesen wäre. Und ich glaube, dass diese Statistik Darmstadt einfach einhoh… Ich bin sehr froh, dass die die Werte in der Mannschaft auf lange Sicht geholt haben und dass sie jetzt so ein bisschen das Nachsehen haben im Vergleich zu Mannschaften, bei denen das eher zueinander passt. Ich weiß, dass diese XG-Werte, die werden unterschiedlich erhoben und unterschiedliche Plattformen kommen dazu, unterschiedliche Faktoren. Ich würde im Kontext Damenstadt 98 trotzdem die These aufstellen wollen, dass sich gerade zeigt, dass die Ergebnisse, die sie an die Tabellenspitze geführt haben, zusammenhängen damit, dass die Ergebnisse besser waren als die spielerische Leistung oder das zu erwartende Ergebnis.
Ja, finde ich auf jeden Fall ein provokant wie auch interessanten Take, ehrlich gesagt. Also ich musste daran tatsächlich auch nochmal, ich muss einmal nochmal in Verbindung zur Bundesliga ziehen. Bitte, liebe Darmstadt-Fans, ist es rein sportlich gemeint, nicht irgendwie auf anderer Basis, aber hoffne einen. Bei denen passiert gerade genau das Gleiche, was wir so schön Regression zur Mitte nennen, nämlich eine Leistung über einen Großteil der Saison, wo man sich da fragt oder wo man vielleicht positiv überrascht ist, wo man auch gute, weil ich möchte trotzdem auch sagen, es waren trotzdem auch gute Taktiken im Spiel dabei, es gab gute Einstellungen von Kohfeldt auf die jeweiligen Gegner, natürlich eben auch gute individuelle Leistungen, aber du kommst jetzt in eine Phase rein, wo du dich ein bisschen fragst, aber was war denn eigentlich auch der Plan? Also ich weiß, das hat Matthias Kneifel eben mir auch so nach dem Bielefeldspiel, das hat er ja auch in der Gruppe bestätigt, also musste da schon sagen, diese 1-0-Führung war eben per se schon mal schmeichelhaft, ist halt eher ein Fehler der Bielefelder, als dass es wirklich von der Qualität der Darmstädter war. Und dann muss man sagen, gab es eine zweite Halbzeit, in der Darmstadt nichts mehr gemacht hat, ehrlich gesagt. Also in dem offensiv, wie auch generell, jegliche taktische Einstellung fehlte, und das war gegen Hannover Minute 1 so. Nur, dass eben diesmal kein Ball durchgerutscht ist, um es mal provokant auszudrücken. Und das ist halt was, was ich sonst bis auf, nee, was ich sonst eigentlich wenig gesehen habe von Darmstadt in dieser Saison. Und was, glaube ich, wo du dann eben einen Florian Kohfeldt siehst, der vor allem im Spiel sehr emotional reagiert, wo ich sagen muss, ich finde seine Aussagen wiederum nach dem Spiel, wo er meistens sehr, also wie so ein anderes Gesicht zeigt, finde ich meistens um einiges spielbezogener als die Reaktion, die er zum Teil im Spiel zeigt. Ich weiß immer nicht, ob er dadurch irgendwie anstacheln will, ob das einfach seine Art ist und dann vielleicht im Umkehrschluss irgendwie selber in sich geht. Ich weiß es nicht, ich bin dafür auch ehrlich gesagt zu weit weg von 98. Aber ich finde das jetzt wirklich zwei Spiele, die mir als Darmstadt-Fan wirklich Sorgen machen würden und wo ich auch durchgelesen habe, so ein bisschen, wo halt wirklich die Frage war, also man kann ja verlieren, ihr habt es eben schon gesagt, aber ich frage wirklich bei beiden Partien, was war denn die Idee? Also ich habe zum Beispiel, wenn ich schon zweimal wechseln muss, klar kannst du das vielleicht leistungstechnisch von Marco Richter irgendwie erklären, aber ich hätte den allein durch die Qualität, die er ja doch mitbringen kann, hätte ich den alleine auf dem Platz gelassen, ehrlich gesagt. Das habe ich irgendwie, ja, und die, also diese mannschaftliche Geschlossenheit, die Darmstadt zwischendurch auch schon durchaus geschafft hat und das Gefühl hatte, es ist doch in größtenteils egal, wer vielleicht im Mittelfeld-Verbund raussteht, das fehlt ihnen irgendwie. Lisa?
Ja, ich glaube, was jetzt total spannend wird, wir haben ja eigentlich bei allen Teams auch so ein bisschen auf die letzten Spiele geblickt, ist halt wirklich an der Stelle auch das Restprogramm. Also klar, gegen Fürth, ich will nicht sagen, das ist ein wegweisendes Spiel so, das kann man gefühlt jetzt zu jedem Spiel sagen, aber das muss man natürlich auch gewinnen. Das könnte eine gute Gelegenheit sein aus Darmstads Sicht, um nochmal einen anderen Schnack wieder reinzubringen, um irgendwie Selbstvertrauen zu tanken, wenn man sieht, wie Fürth eben auch gerade spielt und wo die so stehen. Aber dann so richtig spannend ehrlicherweise, natürlich Elbersberg und letzter Spieltag, vielleicht der Reihenfolge nach, also als Nächstes jetzt in Fürth, dann zu Hause gegen Elbersberg, dann nochmal in Karlsruhe bei Preußen Münster. Auch nochmal ein spannendes Ding. Und am letzten Spieltag natürlich gegen Paderborn. Also ich finde, da sind jetzt noch so ein paar Momente dabei, ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, die werden entscheidend. Aber ich glaube, gerade so die nächsten zwei Spiele gegen Fürth und Elbersberg könnten nochmal so ein bisschen Aufschluss geben über das, was du gerade schon so angeteased hast. Eva mit, was ist die Idee, wo soll es hingehen, was ist gerade los. Aber halt auch in der Konstellation, in der Tabelle. Also das finde ich wird jetzt nicht uninteressant, ehrlicherweise. Und auch da, ja, also ich weiß nicht, ob ich zu negativ bin, aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich jetzt gerade so mit Darmstadt gehen würde.
Ja, es ist eben einfach so, dass sie sich die positive Ausgangslage, ich habe es am Anfang einmal gesagt, die haben sie jetzt halt zuletzt einfach leider ein bisschen hergegeben. Und klar, auch hier herrscht vielleicht anderer Druck als an anderen Standorten. Ja, also weniger, aber trotzdem muss man halt einfach rein sportlich sagen, dass da Fragezeichen bestehen bleiben. Und da bin ich auch sehr gespannt, was wir da jetzt sehen. Ich würde aber auch angesichts der Zeit sagen, liebe Darmstadt-Fans, bitte verzeiht es mir, wir schauen noch einmal auf Hannover 96. Die haben sich nämlich jetzt ja auf Platz 3 vorgekämpft. 53 Punkte, 49 zu 35 Tore, 15 Siege, 8 Unentschieden, 6 Niederlagen. Eine Formtabelle auf Platz 5 mit 2 Siegen, 2 Unentschieden. Eine Niederlage, nachdem wir eben über das 1-1 gegen Elbersberg gesprochen haben. Ich würde es jetzt einfach als durchwachsen, neutral betrachten. Der natürlich schon ein komplett anderer Auftritt gegen Darmstadt. Wie gesagt, es ist die erste Mannschaft seit 11 Monaten, aber eben auch in dieser Saison, die es geschafft hat, Darmstadt zu Hause zu schlagen. Anna, ich weiß ja, du bist ja doch näher dran an Hannover 96, manchmal gerne, manchmal ungern, weiß ich nicht, wie man es ausdrücken möchte. Wie blickst du denn jetzt auf 96?
Insgesamt interessiert, würde ich sagen, weil ich übe mich jetzt diese ganze Folge einfach weiterhin in Diplomatie. Das, was ich an Hannover 96 und dem Umfeld sehr schätze, ist eine gewisse Unaufgeregtheit in Bezug auf so das eigene Selbstverständnis von Einzigartigkeit, weil ja Fußballfans gerne erzählen, wir sind der einzige Club in dem, und wir sind die einzige Fanszene, die und so weiter und so fort. Und so diese Sehnsucht danach, das ganz besondere Kerzchen auf der Bundesligatorte zu sein, das verspüre ich hier sehr selten und das schätze ich sehr, dass man hier einfach niedersächsisch vorgeht und halt am Wochenende zu den Spielen und das relativ unaufgeregt gestaltet. Auf der einen Seite. Auf der anderen Seite bemerke ich eine– vielleicht passt das auch dazu– die 2. Also das ist das zweitbeste Auswärtsteam. Die stehen jetzt ganz oben in der Tabelle. Die haben sich so aus einem immer währenden Mittelfeld jetzt auf einen Relegationsplatz vorgearbeitet. Sie kompensieren Verletzungsausfälle. Sie kompensieren immer wieder doch Schiedsrichterunglück, möchte ich schon sagen. Dass sich das häuft und dass ich nachvollziehen kann, dass da Unzufriedenheit besteht über die Entscheidungen des Schiedsrichtergespanns. Und dass darüber irgendwie sich nicht angemessen gefreut wird, finde ich. Also ich am anderen Ende der Tabelle als Braunschweigerin habe dann manchmal so den Eindruck, ich bin die Verhungernde und derjenige mit viel Essen sagt, es schmeckt ihm nicht so richtig. Und daran stoße ich mich manchmal, weil ich finde, dass 96 insgesamt wirklich eine richtig gute Saison spielt. Ich sehe die gerne Fußball spielen. Ich finde, dass Tiz ein Upgrade ist im Vergleich zu Leite. Ich finde, dass Tiz die Mannschaft insgesamt stabil hält, trotz diesem ganzen Schmatke-Gemache und diesem internen Hin und Her und der dann doch immer wieder latenten Unruhe im Umfeld des Vereins. Ich finde den Fußball, den sie spielen, spannend, dass sie zu wenig Tore machen im Vergleich zu den Chancen, die sie sich rausspielen. Mag so sein, scheint jetzt aber am Ende eben doch ja insgesamt in die richtige Richtung zu führen. Und ich bin sehr, sehr gespannt, wie die jetzt den Schlussspurt gestalten, weil ich da schon das Potenzial sehe, jetzt am Samstag gegen Paderborn noch mal einen richtig großen Schritt zu machen. Ich sehe aber auch die Möglichkeit, dass sie wieder in so eine Liturgie fallen und dann am Ende halt so 5-Star werden, weil irgendwie weiß man auch nicht so richtig. Und ich würde, glaube ich, jetzt abschließen damit, dass ich den Eindruck habe, dass sich diese Spitzengruppe teilt in Mannschaften, die sehr selbstbewusst aufsteigen wollen und sich trauen, das zu artikulieren und sich davon ziehen lassen. Und Mannschaften wie Darmstadt oder auch Hannover, bei denen das zwar irgendwie klar ist, aber ach nee, dafür ist man irgendwie zu bescheiden. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das am Ende den Unterschied machen wird.
Ich glaube, ich habe sehr selten gehört, dass jemand Hannover 96 als bescheiden bezeichnet hat. Das finde ich sehr interessant. Also mal zum Endspurt im Samstag gegen den SC Paderborn. Ich sage mal so, da dürftest du dir nicht erlauben, eine schlechte Effizienz an den Tag zu legen. Das setzt einfach schon mal mit Blick auf das 4 zu 3 vom SC P gegen Magdeburg als Hinweis. Dann muss man ehrlich gesagt sagen, spielt man gegen drei Teams für die die Saison– ich sage es jetzt nochmal, Lisa, mach damit, was du willst, mehr oder weniger vorbei ist. Also je nachdem– Ich verschrei das nicht.
Also als Clubfan, man hat schon alles erlebt. Ich glaube, das versteht auch nur Clubfans.
Nee, ich verstehe das wirklich auch. Man spielt eben gegen Paderborn, dann spielt man auswärts bei Karlsruhe. Haben wir eben schon mal drüber geredet. 40 Punkte. Das Ding müsste eigentlich durch sein. Zu Hause gegen Preußen Münster. Und dann auswärts beim VfL Bochum. Und zu Hause gegen Nürnberg. Gerade Bochum-Nürnberg waren zwei Partien in der Hinrunde, wo man einmal gewinnen muss. Also eigentlich zweimal gewinnen muss. Einmal verschießt man einen entscheidenden Elfmeter und einmal lässt man Nürnberg zweimal einfach viel zu viel Raum. Mal schauen, wie sich das jetzt in der Rückrunde gestaltet. Aber wie gesagt, da muss man sagen, also ich gehe davon aus, für drei von vier Vereine geht es da um die goldene Ananas. Ehrlich gesagt noch, weil ich auch wenn Bochum rechnerisch noch lange nicht gerettet ist. Ich sage da gerne nochmal, für mich haben sie drei Punkte zu viel seit dem Sieg gegen Braunschweig. Sorry Anna, ich muss es einmal noch noch sagen, weil da also wie gesagt, der Rest nimmt sich da irgendwann noch die Punkte mit. Das sollte dann eventuell da gegessen sein. Ich muss sagen, ich war Teil der Menschen, die Hannover's Leistung zuletzt etwas kritisiert haben. Weil ich fand, boah ja vielleicht spätestens seit dem Duell gegen Dynamo Dresden, hat man zwar die Siege geholt, aber sowohl die Partie gegen Bielefeld, die man zwar gewinnt, als auch die Partie gegen Braunschweig, Anna widerspricht mir da gerne, aber war jetzt kein, ach das muss man gewinnen, und da fehlte einfach die Effizienz vom Tor, dass es nicht 3 oder 4-0 aufs geht. So, wäre mein Take zu den beiden Spielen auf jeden Fall. 1-1 gegen... gut, ich glaube, wirklich, wirklich wichtig war, dass man dieses Spiel gegen Schalke ganz spät noch den Punkt holt. Sonst reden wir von einer anderen Ausgangslage, nicht nur, weil man eben zwei Punkte weniger hat, einen Punkt weniger hat, sondern eben, weil man auch generell eine Tabelle da anders wider angelassen hat. Und auch gegen Elbersberg trotz dieses Elfmeters nicht zu verlieren war sicherlich wichtig. Aber jetzt eben diesen Sieg zu holen, ich denke mal, das wird dann doch nochmal ausschlaggebend sein. Ja, weiß ich jetzt nicht, was wir da... Also bei Hannover bin ich mir unsicher, ehrlich gesagt, was wir da vom Rest noch erwarten können, um das vielleicht abzubinden. Lisa, guck mal, ich wollte dich gerade sogar noch weiterfangen, da hebst du hier schon virtuell die Hand.
Ja, ich finde mich tatsächlich bei Hannover so ganz spannend, dass es so im Verlauf ja immer wieder so kleinere Rückschläge, sage ich mal, gab. Aber ich da immer das Gefühl hatte, die haben sich immer wieder zu einem guten Moment, sage ich mal, da auch rausgearbeitet. Also ich habe oder wir hatten das ja vorhin, als wir über Pförd gesprochen haben, das vergisst man, finde ich, so schnell. Die haben einfach gegen Pörd verloren. Das waren so Momente, da hätte so eine Saison auch kippen können. Und da hatte ich das Gefühl, hat man das bei Hannover ganz gut immer wieder geschafft, dass das halt nicht passiert. Und du hast das gerade erwähnt, das 1-1 gegen Schalke war, glaube ich, auch so ein Moment. Und jetzt auch am Wochenende…
2-2, Entschuldigung, das 2-2 gegen Schalke.
Das Unentschieden. Und ich glaube, auch jetzt das Topspiel am Wochenende könnte so ein Moment sein, der dann natürlich total wegweisend ist aufgrund der Konstellation. Aber um auch jetzt nochmal zu untermauern, wie geht man in diesen Endspurt? Also mit Blick aufs Programm, ja, da ist viel möglich. Ich gucke denen auch sehr, sehr gerne zu. Also ich glaube, das hat Anna schon total schön zusammengefasst, was da irgendwie alles passiert ist dieses Jahr. Auch so den Titsball, den mag ich schon auch gerne. Guck ich auch ein bisschen neidisch manchmal, also ein bisschen nach Hannover. Mal gucken, der letzte Spieltag, dann gegen den Club. So wie die Gesamtgemengelage ist, glaube ich schon, das Hannover, das packt ehrlicherweise diese Saison, auch mit dem kleinen Poster, das es ja jetzt schon gibt. Für mich wäre dann eher der nächste Gedanke, ist das ein Team, das dann auch bundesligareif ist. Und das ist jetzt schon sehr, sehr weiter gedacht, I know. Aber da würde ich dann eher so die Zweifel vielleicht irgendwie sehen, dass ich da das Gefühl hätte, das wird dann schon sportlich. Also da müsste, glaube ich, im Sommer dann auch noch mal einiges passieren. Ich weiß, soweit sind wir noch gar nicht. Aber da bin ich irgendwie bei Hannover gedanklich schon so ein bisschen, wo ich zum Beispiel bei Schalke ein bisschen anderes Gefühl hätte, wenn wir jetzt schon über die Saison hinaus denken.
Anna, gerne.
Ja, würde ich beipflichten. Ich glaube, der einzige Verein, der diese Bundesliga-Reife jetzt schon andeutet, ist Schalke 04. Und dass diejenigen, die hinter Schalke rangieren, das tun, weil sie davon profitieren, dass andere nicht gepunktet haben. Also Eva, du hattest das ja skizziert, dieses Tief von Hannover, beziehungsweise gegen Fürth verloren, gegen uns nicht gut gespielt. Aber es reicht halt in der Zweien-Liga. Und diesen Faktor darfst du ja auch nicht rausrechnen, dass das irgendwie viel nicht nur mit Timing zu tun hat, wie lang sind deine guten und deine schlechten Phasen, sondern auch gegen wen gewinnst du diese Spiele. Und Hannover hatte bisher kein einziges Spitzenspiel gewonnen, bis jetzt Darmstadt. Und das war für mich immer ein Faktor zu sagen, dann reicht es halt nicht für oben. Weil irgendwie musst du ja gegen die Konkurrenz in der Zweiten Liga bestehen und nicht nur da oben landen, weil du gegen die Unteren deine Punkte holst und deine Konkurrenz irgendwie versiebt, sondern auch innerhalb der Liga gegen die Top-Teams bestehen. Und das war jetzt irgendwie ein ganz spannender Punkt, dass das in Darmstadt so überzeugend funktioniert hat. Paderborn ist, finde ich, noch mal ein anderes Niveau, weil die so archal spielen. Also es kann halt irgendwie, da fallen irgendwie mehr Tore und denen ist irgendwie mehr egal, ob sie Gegentore fangen. Das sind so andere Vorzeichen, unter denen dieses Spiel steht. Ich finde, alles unter Schalke ist wirklich sehr schwer zu prognostizieren. Weil wie gesagt, ich habe Hannover auch schon absolut nicht gut gesehen. Aber auch leidvoll erfahren, dass sie zwar einerseits darüber klagen, wir waren so gut, wir haben die Tore nicht gemacht. Und der Schiedsrichter war gemein zu uns. Auf der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite die Punkte holen, obwohl sie nicht gut spielen. Und dann gleicht es sich ja am Ende auch wieder aus. Also naja, gut, jetzt sind wir hier schon am Rechenschieber.
Ja, ich glaube, wirklich so der Punkt, den wir von dieser Sendung mitnehmen können, ist, wir machen keine Prognosen mehr. Wir sind ja zum Glück hier irgendwie keine Ärztinnen oder so, die hier der 2. Liga was attestieren müssen und sagen, hier, das verschreiben wir euch jetzt, bitte Rezept abholen. Ich finde, es macht es für uns als Besprechende immer wieder interessant, weil ich glaube, im Gegensatz, in Teilen der Bundesliga beispielsweise, haben wir sehr viel mehr Varianz drin. Trotzdem, ich sag das gerne noch mal, sag das natürlich auch immer ein, hier ist über die Qualität der 2. Liga aus, wenn die Hälfte des Teams zu diesem Punkt gegen den Abstieg spielt. Was ist natürlich schon mal vielleicht so als Hinweis für potenziell Wolfsburg und Heidenheim, vor allem für Wolfsburg, sehr kleine Hinweise. Das könnte eine Nummer werden. Also ich bin sowieso gespannt, weil ich kann mich nicht mehr an Wolfsburg in der 2. Liga erinnern. Ich weiß nicht, wie euch das geht. Aber ja, freuen wir uns schon mal drauf. Also generell, wenn man mal auf die 3. Liga schaut, das könnte eine Saison werden, nächste Saison. Es wird sicherlich eine kuriose 2. Liga. Aber das ist sie sowieso jedes Jahr.
Also wird nicht langweiliger.
Wird nicht langweiliger, gehe ich auch von aus. Aber welche Diagnose ich auf jeden Fall, wirklich auf jeden Fall stellen kann, ist, dass wir am Ende dieser Folge angekommen sind. Und es ist mal wieder länger als geplant, den Wunder. Ich danke als allererstes Lisa Höfer, dass sie mal wieder dabei war. Danke Lisa.
Vielen, vielen Dank fürs Einladen. Es hat total viel Spaß gemacht. Zeit ist verflogen. Und ja, schauen wir, was die letzten Spiele bringen.
Und dann bedanke ich mich auch bei Anna Lautenbach. Danke Anna, dass du auch wieder dabei warst.
Danke schön. Hat mir sehr viel Spaß gemacht.
Und dann hört ihr mich in zwei Wochen hier wieder. Bis dahin, bleibt gesund. Macht's gut.
Tschüss.
Das war der Rasenfunk.
Von Ihnen unterstützt.
Herzlichen Dank. Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.